so many people when they actually travel from
the u.s to europe and they consume wheat products
they have no bloating they don't have near the
digestive problems they don't even necessarily
gain weight now i am definitely not recommending
consuming wheat but i want to talk about the
difference between wheat from america versus wheat
from europe there's a huge difference when people
are consuming breads and pastas and cereals
and crackers and biscuits in the united states
they get acne they get bloating they get a lot of
inflammation in their gut they also have lethargy
they're tired but you don't really see as much
of that in europe at least from the wheat why is
that what is the differences well in america sixty
percent of the wheat is red wheat now what is red
wheat compared to certain countries in europe they
use white wheat so red wheat is soft it's fluffy
it has a longer shelf life it has a lot more
carbohydrate and it has much more protein
specifically gluten the wheat that they use in
europe has much less gluten that's the protein in
wheat that causes a lot of the problems in the gut
but that's not the only difference in america the
wheat is not necessarily genetically modified but
they use glyphosate in a lot of the wheat which is
the chemical they normally spray on genetically
modified crops now they say glyphosate is not
harmful to humans it's only harmful to bacteria
but the problem is humans have a lot of bacteria
growing inside and outside their bodies in fact
humans are dependent on their microorganisms
so glyphosate directly attacks this microbiome and
disturbs the flora and the ability for someone to
digest now gmo foods in general and glyphosate
is banned in many european countries now there's
one more point i want to bring up but it has to do
with iron fortification so in grain products that
are refined they tend to fortify it with synthetic
vitamins and iron and of course the source of iron
that they're using to fortify is actually not
the type that your body can easily break down
this type of iron that's fortified in
wheat in america kind of sits in your gut
it tends to generate more pathogenic bacteria
and then if we compare this to european countries
like france denmark and sweden and other
countries they use no fortification at all
so i just wanted to do this video to talk about
the difference from the america versus european
wheat of course i'm not recommending consuming
wheat i'm just talking about the difference so
if you're enjoying my content which i hope you are
and you're applying this knowledge to your health
and you have a success i'd really appreciate you
sharing your success story so click the link down
below to my website where you can upload your
success story so you can help inspire others